like i feel like taxi drivers here are
very aware of that
because i mean most people in japan
especially in the service industry are
[ __ ] super off they do not rip you
off at all because i remember
um had to take like a pretty long taxi
that went via the highway but there was
like really bad traffic there on that
day
and so it took like i think like 20
minutes longer than the journey should
have taken
yeah and the taxi driver like he told me
that he was gonna stop the meter early
because he feels bad that they were
stuck in traffic for so long
even though they went via the highway so
i'm just like man that's not even his
fault yeah that's not even your fault
you're a real one man you're a real when
you taxi you just gamble man maybe the
highways are congested that's yeah
that's that's the risk
that's just part of the risk and i know
i feel like just taxi drivers
or anyone like it's so weird to me that
you can't tip people here
because out of every country that i've
lived in and been to
the one country i've wanted to tip
people the most is here in japan
yeah and it's it's just like
it's it feels bad because i've gotten
some of the best service i ever have
anywhere in the world and i can't pay
them a bit more to show my appreciation
you know i think the only service in
japan that you can actually tip people
is ubereats
that's just yeah integrated but that's
just because it's uber yeah
which is an international company right
i always tip if it's raining
i feel so bad for that when i order food
when it's raining yeah yeah
they turn up at the door [ __ ] soaked
and um yeah especially when it's like
typhoon season as well you're just like
damn man like three three dollars okay
three dollars for your trouble sir
it was such an awful experience it was
just yeah yeah and i felt so bad because
i
i was in like i was trying to optimize
it so i ordered food
yeah like lunch uh to arrive at the
studio for when i was gonna get there
and then i was like jerry can you can
you get
uber no because i was waiting at the
studio and and connor was like yeah i'm
10 minutes away and i was like cool
i'll see him very soon then like 30
minutes past i'm like
where is he yes i saw that in the like
the message stream because i wasn't
there at the studio that day
and i was like why is conor telling joey
to get his food yeah like this
this white boy getting more privileged
every day
i don't want to deal with you
i can't speak japanese
jesus christ man that's why i was scared
man to get on taxis because it's like
again it's like in japan 85
of the time they're like over the age of
70. and i and i just don't know what to
expect it's like some
sometimes they're the most like pristine
proper like you know [ __ ]
batman's assistant levels of like
amazing driving but then
sometimes you get people like that right
where it's like you shouldn't be behind
a steering wheel yeah i had a guy one
time i got in the car she started
thinking like fluid english to me and i
was like whoa
whoa he's like are you comfortable with
the ac
what did you say in like a really
dominating voice yeah
yeah yeah like the man said like psy
from like gangnam oh yeah
he's just like like like like was he old
no no he
looked like 30. oh well that's like
what's up right there what are you doing
doing doing being a taxi driver yeah i
was so confused i was like
i was just so caught off guard by it i
was like i was like yeah yes yeah it's
great it's great well
they don't ask you anything normally if
someone's below the age of 60
they do they like you rarely see someone
below the age of 60 be a taxi driver
especially here in japan um